vamos a resolver algunos problemas
acerca de clasificación de ángulos en
este ejercicio nos preguntan cuáles de
los ángulos etiquetados en el diagrama
siguiente son ángulos agudos como
recordatorio un ángulo es agudo si mide
menos de 90 grados vamos a ver la figura
el ángulo b y el ángulo de se ven muy
grandes se ve que son más grandes de 90
grados entonces pues no estos de aquí no
son agudos y el a y el c si se ve que
miden menos de 90 grados y por lo tanto
serían las respuestas correctas a ese
excelente siguiente pregunta otra vez
cuáles de los ángulos etiquetados en el
diagrama siguiente son ángulos agudos
bueno pues a ese se ven mayores a 90
grados 20 se ven menores a 90 grados por
lo tanto la respuesta es b y de esos son
los ángulos agudos muy bien a ver este
es un tipo de ejercicio distinto dice
selecciona un signo del menú desplegable
para completar las proposiciones
siguientes después responde la pregunta
el ángulo a es a mira tiene tiene signos
de comparación el ángulo como es con
respecto a 90 grados pues es menor menor
a 90 grados como el ángulo es menor a 90
grados entonces es un ángulo un ángulo
agudo
muy bien siguiente pregunta nos dicen
qué tipo de ángulo es el que está
resaltado en verde bueno aquí ponen una
pizza que se ve muy rica y ponen un
ángulo un ángulo que se ve pequeño esta
es una rebanada de pizza pequeña justo
porque este ángulo es pequeño es menor a
90 grados y por lo tanto es un ángulo
agudo vamos a hacer uno más porque está
muy divertido esto muy bien
otra vez es de este tipo dice usando el
diagrama a continuación
ahí está selecciona un signo del menú ok
el ángulo a es mayor mayor a 90 grados y
por lo tanto el ángulo es obtuso los
ángulos obtusos son aquellos que miden
más de 90 grados
excelente